yeah I presented to you a pretty normal
situation now maybe you're like what
well what happened to my zero to three
hours of three parking well
welcome welcome to the city so if you
don't know world square is on the street
in the city it's approximately halfway
between qbb the Crematory Building and
the Central Station that's a very very
rough approximation okay but that these
your rough sense of where it is and
these kinds of charges are totally
normal in the city totally normal so
that's that's pretty much a given all
right sir
sir I wouldn't be surprised now by the
way can I just say I mentioned to who is
here early yeah that most people are not
actually even worrying about all of this
they're just here like at the car park
all day because you know they work in
the city and for whatever reason they
don't take probably transport so they're
just staring down they see every single
day well sometimes that is unfortunate
but yes
okay now yes welcome to Australia what I
want us to do is take this data and put
it onto here because this is um this is
a set of this is a set of points right a
set of points is all you need to make a
graph right like whoever we were talking
about the set of the idea of functions
and relations actually look bigger
here's a set of values and they are
paired with another set of values this
is a bit complicated okay so I have a
cost axis and I have a really shitty
sedition time actually it's me time axis
I've got dollars going up and I've got
hours going right okay now let's pick a
scale here you have a look at the value
let's let me do that okay I didn't know
if they were just trying to UM they're
just trying to mess with the OCD people
to make this 11 22 33 44 oh good job oh
yeah it was to get to this wasn't it I
don't know anyway um let's take this
graph and I'm going to suggest well
because these are the only numbers that
we're interested in rather than have
like a 10 20 30 40 etcetera scale who's
gonna put these numbers on there like
most of them most of them they're gonna
have it even stale it's just this one
which is a bit of a gap okay so let's
you're gonna need seven markings
you have seven markings right at eleven
dollar increments so that means I've got
eleven here 22 here 33 44 I will write
in 55 and 66 because they will help me
place that awkward number and 77 at the
top now our horizontal axis suggestions
what am I gonna need across the bum
again how far am I gonna have to go I'm
gonna have to go up to six right by the
way even though it doesn't say what's
happening like six plus you can there's
enough information either to determine
what's happening for longer than six
hours what would you conclude yeah it's
just gonna stop like it's just gonna
keep on going at this rate
partly I would guess from this like if
you've lost your ticket we have no idea
how long you've been he said that's why
we charge you the maximum amount does
that make sense
okay so therefore let's have that Marx
guess the moral of story is don't okay
so one hour two hours three and so on
now as we've just pointed out right
the second you drive into this I mean we
have no other information like maybe
maybe this tiny illegible font there
might be something about like or some
kind of you know leave within half an
hour of paying some 15-minute grace
period something like that it's the sea
so I'm not expect to be as much of a
great
the second you enter the second you
enter the machine spits out the ticket
right you've been charged right you've
been charged so therefore at zero like
right there at zero I'm already up here
at eleven dollars sound right does that
make sense
now after half an hour oh that's just to
suppose I stay for 30 minutes okay and
then I live how much am I going to be
charged still 11 dollars right now again
this whole idea of ordered pairs that's
what that's what functions are about
right this set of ordered pairs are
gonna look like this right and in fact
like I don't need to make this screen
dots this line is just gonna go all the
way across because there's no like any
part of these it's not like you know at
five minute increments or something like
that it's just going to track along at
that amount
okay now I'll come back to you what
exactly happens at an hour and come back
to that will return but let's just think
about what happens now I've safely gone
out over an hour right so now I'm like
an hour and five minutes and I'm 15 or
whatever I've bumped up haven't I all
right so I'm at $22 yeah and you can see
what's gonna happen you can follow the
pattern so I'm gonna have this get two
circles are the same
well well I'm not going to and you'll
see why anything now we haven't put $60
on there which is the the fee that I'm
up to at the moment but because I have
55 and 66 well roughly halfway between
those should be fine okay
now as we said I'm just adding a teeny
bit of information on to here that is
implied but it isn't there which is that
after I break that six hour barrier it
just keeps on going they're not going to
charge me more because the horse ticket
price just kind of caps up there okay
all right now this thing here right this
has a name because of this very
predictable kind of shape that we've got
here right this is called does anyone
know what school it's not for the next
it's called a step graph this is a step
graph right because it literally looks
like a set of steps going up